yeah I mean Adrienne can come in yes
Stuart can join us they're gonna dump
welcome to Jim Norton Sam Roberts you
being here in a studio that's what we do
hmm fancy you being here huh well what I
do I guess so I guess that's right what
do you enjoy it a lot of people hate
going out and doing doing press for a
project they hate it or some people love
it you know what I love to talk and I
got a billion stories you can never shut
me up really really uh that we just did
something else and it went by and a half
an hour I thought I said one thing and
it was just have you always been that
way or was it when you started
interacting with I don't think I was
always that way but you know after you
have enough experiences you got your
story sure like I got it's like
something any anything you mentioned I
can probably say something about because
oral sex hey what's that
albums did you work on or did you work
really just live well I was on the shaky
booty album that's one of my favorite
records of all time and I did the Bob
Dylan imitation that was on there in a
song called flakes and the way that
happened I was hanging out at Frank's
house one night and he was showing me
some music that he would be teaching the
band the next week and he was writing a
song called flakes and when he played it
for me it sounded like a really bad folk
song so I started making fun of it and I
said started singing it and he said
that's it yeah I'll be finished by
Friday yeah that's so great it is well
my favorite albums ever was later Paul
Simon actually introduced me to Bob
Dylan who was standing in the stairwell
at the club at a club here in New York
just walked over and opened the door and
said I wanted to introduce you to
somebody opens the door and there's Bob
Dylan standing in the stairwell and he
said Bob here's Adrian blue and Bob said
have you heard your impression in the
song and that's what I always wanted to
know what did he hear of me he never
said any more so I mean as left I was
left with what did you hear why didn't
you ask him I was starstruck you were I
was starstruck plus you never want to
ask you here the impression I did have
yes
by the way Bobby Brown off that album
could be Bobby Brown goes down could be
my favorite song of all time well I'll
tell Frank that when I see him hopefully
soon how did you know he was like one of
those guys I wouldn't go to a doctor
right Frank yeah I asked him that but I
knew him very well because I was the one
guy in the band who didn't read music
totally self-taught so we would rehearse
five days a week in a big film studio on
Friday night I would get in his car go
home with him and spend the weekend
there and he would show me the upcoming
things Allah that's why just a story I
just told so for three months i
virtually lived in frank zappa's house
every weekend Wow which I have a lot of
stories to tell about was he a wild
liver was it was he like a kind of a
clean life or was the it was a very
clean living guy and the hardest-working
person I can ever recall working I mean
just worked from the time he he slept
late and then he worked all day and all
night yeah they said Prince did that too
I guess a lot of musicians are on their
own schedule you guys kind of have a you
know you're not 9 to 5 people hi Stuart
Frank Zappa and how he would sleep how
he would
I guess sleep all day and then work at
night work a lot was very hardworking
guy was he one of those guys like like
again like Prince who would just kind of
go I got an idea and then just get it
together no not at all like that he was
very controlled not an idea like here's
my idea it was sort of here's the music
play it correctly okay
he had a definite idea of what he wanted
most everything was done deliberately
yeah and it wasn't you know working in
Frank's man wasn't where you got to do
your own thing it was where you got to
do his thing correctly and consistently
but that was okay because that's exactly
what I needed at that point in my life
sort of a year's worth of tutelage you
know I'm self-taught I'd never had
anybody show
me how to play in 7/8 until I met Frank
the next year I played with David Bowie
it was just the opposite David just
wanted me to go wild and would never
give me any ants any instruction so
there you go
and Stewart welcome to the show what
kind of just complete that thought sure
my favorite brag about Adrian this is
the man stolen from Frank Zappa by David
Bowie TV nevermind Talking Heads
Graceland all the other the man who was
stolen from Frank Zappa by David Bowie I
give you
Adrian balloon I am isn't a nice little
resume header yeah I'm usually passed
around like a [ __ ] at a party you're
actually stolen by one genius from
another yes so uh you your life is
interesting to me too like you know your
father was really one of the founding
members in the CIA so it is said Wow so
did you grow up like just involved in
government your whole life when you were
a kid not at all no no I'm I grew up in
weird places when I was 2 months old I
left Langley Virginia when I was where I
was born
to go to Cairo Egypt where my father had
just installed a new dictator Gamal
Abdel Nasser hafting having kicked out
King Farouk and then later the family
moved to Beirut Lebanon which is where I
did most of my growing up and I didn't
get back to America till I was 18 oh wow
but during none of that time were really
actually did for a living so it's really
like that in the CIA family like nobody
knows what Dad does well I guess my
mother knew but she one of my father's
best friends was a British agent name of
Harry Harry Philby who turned out to be
a double agent and is we had parallel
families his kids were we're the same
age as the Copeland kids the filthy kids
and my buddy Phillip I mean Harry Philby
was um he was my buddy and one day their
daddy disappeared uh and two weeks later
turned out he showed up in Moscow he had
been a double agent
all this time Wow what did dad say when
you said what do you do dad yeah well no
my brother miles came home from school
one day and says dad are you
spy and this is this is a family story
and my father says who wants to know but
I mean at like 16 you got to have some
like it's not like your Dino kid like do
you follow your father's well you're in
baby no you know you don't you're in
Beirut you're a teenager more interested
in girls than what dad's but you didn't
understand why you were in Beirut like
oh right well I didn't had never lived
anywhere else so it wasn't weird so it
wasn't weird at all
yeah but when I was in college right in
the height of the I end a crisis and
Chile
that's when my father had retired and he
wrote his book and on the liner notes of
his book is where I discovered what my
daddy did for a living
so you really and it's all this is on
news to you yeah well my except that you
know later in later years my mother said
you could always tell who was the spot
and in Beirut almost everybody but he
was the spine you could tell the spies
by how much rubbish they talked mm-hmm
you know they they could never get hairy
like Kim Philby you could never never
get him to talk seriously about anything
he would talk about the races the the
the weather the quickest way to Damascus
anything but politics because the minute
you start talking about what you
actually do you're in trouble that's
right yeah
so he was your dad's life in danger all
this time like you know being oh well
probably not well actually no the reason
we left Lebanon is because it got hot
there was uh there was one flare-up but
there was only one war in Beirut while I
was there in 1958 and in those days the
United States Sixth Fleet just showed up
on the horizon and the war was over just
the idea of them showing up and they did
it just just to entertain the folks of
Lebanon they did a little demonstration
on the beach where they had these
gigantic tanks just firing a little
target practice there and those it's
pretty impressive when the 6th fleet
shows up in the you know filling the
horizon ok everybody let's go home they
had an election they elect actually
elected an anti-american guy but it's
cool you know sure
and those were the days when we had a
lot more credibility than we do now ouch
yeah I guess it's uh there were times we
were liked a little more
nowadays our fleet our seventh fleet get
you know the way to defeat America is to
go send out tankers
it's literally four accidents in a year
isn't every year that it wouldn't
embarrassment they they ceased all Navy
Navy operations for like one day we
unheard-of yeah my father was kind of
mysterious to me - what'd he do he drove
a truck for a plumbing company so he
says mysterious is one day I was
downtown and I saw him drive by in his
truck and he was smoking a cigarette and
I had no idea smoke cigarettes his dad
do you drive a truck and he says I'm
amazed by people who hide smoking
because I've known relationships where
the guy smokes in the water don't tell
my wife how does she not know you're
[ __ ] kissing or you're showing up how
do I know you smoked these smelly smoke
well I didn't know he smoked but after
all I didn't kiss him that much but we
must hug him like I did hug him and he
kind of smelled funny now like that then
he gave me work for a plumbing company
so you know it could be something else
pipes maybe you smoked a pipe that's the
best option if you work for upon the
company pipes yeah you guys have put
together this like kind of it's being
called a supergroup I'd call it a
supergroup we've got a new name for it
just a little little background a little
background yes yes I came because of
just the joy of going to Italy and
having a great time there and originally
for about 10 years been going there I
with no agenda no product no promo no
anything just to be in Italy in the
summer and play these open-air shows
under the Italian sky and so the agenda
if there was an agenda was pasta so now
when people are calling us a super group
right we correct them by saying we are
in fact a supper group but like it has
to be at this point refreshing because
you guys have had all this success so
it's not like you're like chasing after
that thing that you haven't been there
before about fun it's just about fun and
music now right in our band
motto was look nobody sane is ever gonna
hear this right
[Laughter]
but it's got to be nice though to be a
point in both your careers where you've
done so much stuff yeah it has you've
proven yourself so many times over like
there's no pressure like I got it it's
just a thing that you're just enjoying
doing that's got to be a great place to
be it's a lot of fun that's why we are
doing it because we you know they
invited me over to Milan on on a
trumped-up if I can use that word or
trumped-up business they said you know
you can't use that word I didn't know if
you were allowed to curse on radio now
Stu you don't like when he makes fun of
Trump your trump card you don't like
when he mocks I described as my
machinations my Machiavellian ploy being
described as trumpet worm way too
sophisticated for me I see anyway his
Machiavellian ploy was to get me and
Mark in the band without letting us know
we were joining abandoned and so I
arrived thinking I was gonna play on a
couple of tracks and just sit in the Sun
and have you know have some pasta and
next thing I knew we were in the band
because it was so good that's my point
well you also tell me you write operas
so you kind of you're doing a little bit
of everything and I want to know how do
you conceptualize an opera because I've
never been to one I don't know if I'd
like it it was going great the whole
opera thing the whole you know composer
you know the reason I'm writing big
symphonic works and playing with the
Chicago Symphony and and so on is
because I'm a drummer and the drummers
like the singers and the bass singers
and drummers at opposite ends of the
Jets actually have an invisible bond
we're not sure if we really are
musicians and in the middle of the jet
like the guitarist and the bass player
and keyboard they're talking in some
strange language an f-sharp minor G flat
you know all the stuff and the singer
and the drummer like that are they
talking about me or they're talking
about you you know and then it's a weird
language anyway so you feel a little
left out I do I never would have thought
that the drummer that's where all this
this orchestral music comes from that
basic fundamental insecurity okay but it
was going great I'm playing with these
orchestras around the world I'm writing
big important music and it's going just
great and then this rock band came and
got me this little hobby it wasn't even
on well I guess it was a hobby and Italy
just going there in the summer to bang
on drums which I still enjoyed doing no
matter how highfalutin
the music is I like banging on those
drums and then suddenly that turned into
a real thing with somebody like Adrian
Belew in the band and we get Mark King
on board and I guess I got a drop what
I'm doing and taking this seriously
because it wasn't really that big a deal
cuz it was so much fun that was an easy
call so it was there any party that
didn't want to do that you're like ah
like I've I've lived that that life
before I kind of just want this to be
this thing that we do in Italy for us
not an antipathy to the idea at all I
mean I always love the idea that's why I
would go and kind of do it and pretend
to be a band every summer right but then
it turned into the real thing you're
like let's just run with this I just got
out of a band and I was not in the mood
to join another band at all yes I
already had another band which I've had
for 10 years called the power trio so
it's a good thing that they didn't say
come on over and join a band well you
guys also like being in you you guys
have been in bands that you've had to
deal with some of the biggest egos in
the history of music so I would imagine
that the being in a band is not for
either you guys the most the thing that
you would jump to automatically is that
right well yes and no because you know
both of us can make our own records we
can write things right I mean I just did
a film score for Pixar he does classical
pieces etc we can do all that stuff by
ourselves in our studios which we have
in our homes and that's great and it's
wonderful but sometimes you really want
to have that sort of unseen thing happen
where someone else does something that
changes what you are doing that then
turns into something else and that's
called collaboration and it's called
synergy and it's called many other
things and right you get that with the
right group of people and it happens so
rarely that when you see it as I did in
Milan you say well okay I've got to do
this and you guys as you get older to
like you've been are you've both been in
bands you both dealt with again a lot of
personalities take on from one marriage
by the way kind of just introduce your I
actually haven't had to deal with big
egos oh except for mine I'm just saying
personality
the people I've worked with of generally
this ego thing it's rarely about ego in
fact you know certainly the police there
was never an ego problem except for
maybe me stink didn't have any ego no
come on
totally totally not Wow
okay tantric sex we can have a laugh
about that yes ego no or just say that a
marriage were a bunch of ideas would be
even if it's not ideas yeah in strong
musical opinions oh yeah baby right look
about the one named sting right there
you're like them I got it here's why I
assumed ego and it was an assumption I
assumed ego because I'm like because
he's so goddamn town wait so great pants
but then and he's got the one name a
little bit too handsome and then he
takes the one name and he goes on tour
with like a lute or whatever and he's
not even doing like this stuff everybody
hang on hold for a second here I got
some business to do yeah if he wants to
make a lute album gosh darn it he can
make a darn lute album yes earned it he
made how many hit records oh he can make
a list if he wants to sing an opera Hey
look nobody beats me up for writing
offer I guess they don't expect you know
I don't know why yeah tell you why it's
because the singer is typically not
always but whenever you hear a band not
being together anymore typically the
singer gets blamed because it's that's
he's no frontman right normally the
biggest flake in the band is gonna be
this thing not always but you know again
there that he's the guy to whom everyone
says you don't need these guys right
right yeah the pressure to kid the voice
by the way he's stuck with us long after
you know after like when we were making
our third record it was clear this guy
has a clear vision of the songs he wants
to write and how to make them and he
truly doesn't need these guys but he's
stuck with us for two more records five
records we got out of him and I am
grateful for that I mean he actually is
a very loyal guy yes this is exactly how
I know that I've lived my entire life in
an alter universe because I was in a
band for 33 years I was the front man
and the other guy was the guy who had
all the big issues issues what you know
what what the
play he played guitar okay the guitars
and mellotron he and he was the he was
the the the the issue in the band well
he lot Egan was the band in his mind oh
okay I guess that's tempting that happen
when you get creative I you know when
you're collaborating creatively the
other musicians I've never done it it's
gotta be there's gotta be everyone
thinks that their idea is the right idea
and how do you deal with that then like
do you get what are you gonna go up to
and be like dude how do you tell some
the frontman what are you doing yeah you
never could say the word dude to this
person I don't mr. dude perhaps but
really wouldn't have said dude I dealt
with it i well I dealt with it for 33
years by first of all having a great
relationship with the person and loving
him and then I got an email one day
saying you're not in the band he just
threw you out that's harsh three me
under the couch what was the reason he
went under the bus baby
ouch she's dropped a couch on you drop
the couch on me yeah what was the reason
uh I have yet to ascertain that but I
think it was probably now a mistake I
know what the reason was drugs we have
he wanted to make room on the stage for
for drummers sorry
no room for that guitar anymore we need
for drummers and this was that over
email that was done over evening 33
years no email was it a warm email like
look man this is not it was a terse and
laconic email know what I mean I know
Turkish work okay just like terse same
thing any emojis frowny faces nothing no
not a single emoji did you read did you
regret putting up with this nonsense for
for 33 years after that if you're like
if this is how it was gonna end I would
have told him he was an [ __ ] in the
beginning
come on I do love this person but I it
just goes to show my point I don't know
why I must be a glutton for punishment
well have you talked to him since no how
long have been real that's true love
[Laughter]
three or four years either so you
haven't spoken in three or four years
yeah that's that's gotta be enraging
you're doing the band folder here's a
guy cut you out without any kind of
especially like I know you just don't
and then yeah I went off of won an Oscar
and told you asked a bunch of times and
just you know let's joined a super I
mean a subgroup okay I'm what did you
win the Oscar for score for something
yeah I scored a Pixar short film last
year just came out
Pixar pay well they well for a short
film they don't return they don't make
money on their short cut they do that
because they really enjoyed and it's a
way to show off their their new hardware
and software and stuff and new ideas
short story yes they paid well enough
but the thing comes from the thing that
really comes from it is wind you know
that short film is shown in front of
finding dory the largest most successful
animated film in the history of the
world
I beat Nemo it beat Nemo was its
originator you know I had dinner with
Andrew Stanton last night the man who
made both those movies oh nice and he's
a great guy and we you know I I could
have never imagined that Pixar would
call me to do something so when they did
it was a great honor so when you go to
the Oscars do they I didn't go oh you
didn't go I was on tour
oh yeah busy working the door you
tempted though if it's an Oscar are you
tempted to go alright look we got a gig
but maybe we can move the gig for that
well not if your gigs in Europe and you
gotta okay and you
Vande you know and you're you've got to
feed the guys and girls in the band so
no no no it was it was okay I didn't
have to go I went to the premiere and
that was really fun I mean had a great
time doing that I took my family and my
two daughters and it was really great
fun to see all those people and meet you
know all the stars and hang in Hollywood
did you watch it and then just realize
you I don't know how that works did you
watch it and go like as you're watching
on television realize I won or do they
let you know right before I like it
looks interesting actually the day
before we left for tours when they had
the televised part and my bass player
Julie slick and I were standing in my
kitchen and I said I don't think they
televised the short animated films so
I'm not even gonna watch it she said she
was looking on her iPhone she said no I
think maybe they do in fact I think it
might be coming up now we walked into
the television room turned on the
television and they said and the Oscar
for Best Short animated film Wow
happened just right then at that second
we turned the television on we won boys
not before you and on Tori's if that was
before you went on tour your users day
before we went on tour you just we just
couldn't make this ceremony just I
couldn't I couldn't to myself I couldn't
cancel a tour right yeah but he's only
got one more Oscar than me I spent 20
years scoring films with Oliver Stone
yes Coppola like that what did you score
with us on a couple right with with
Oliver Stone was wall street and talk
radio oh wow okay and Francis Coppola
was my first film actually with rumble
fish he's you know with all that this
guy comes in does one very short film
short film and gosh darn Oscar for that
when you write an opera do you write in
English in operas it always in a time oh
no it's in English oh it is well why
would it be in Italian I don't know I've
never heard an opera so I don't know I
would assume because Mozart wrote in
Italian gosh knows why but I don't know
I would assume an artist he has no idea
yeah I'm being pretty pretty
straightforward I don't know I've never
seen an opera I people say you'll love
it or you hate it we'll come and see
mine I would but do you see it five of
them yeah it's the most fun a composer
can have with his clothes on really it
really is because in in as a film
composer where I learned how to work
with drama and music together and that's
also where I learned how to write music
for Orchestra I got my orchestral
training on someone else's dime namely
Frances Oliver and the rest of my do it
but the relationship with music and
drama is very profound but when you do a
film score or television score or a game
score you're working for the man you're
not really an artist you're craftsmen
yeah serve the art of the director and
that's it's fine the pay is great do
they tell you to do something have you
had this guy are they just answer yes
sir you want it happy sad or sad happy
yeah and guess what there is a
difference sure and so you learn to be
very very specific about the emotional
message you know Tom Cruise looks into
the woman's eyes and says I love you but
the audience needs to know that he's a
lying scumbag but the shot
it's a beauty he's playing of course but
I mean
and so the composer's job is to tell
that message to the audience that the
the woman he's saying it to or man
doesn't know that he's lying but the
audience does and so the thumb composing
is very very specific emotionally and so
taking those skills into opera the
differences that in opera
it's the composer's medium right and the
reason for that is very simple because
all the great opera composers are safely
dead right and so when they put up a
Mozart opera that the soprano and the
conductor can argue endlessly but no
well Mozart wanted this no life
mozart wanted that and so the whole
dialogue is about what the composer
wanted now if a living composer walks
into the room we can resolve this issue
right now here is what I want
write your thing yeah so the whole thing
is set up as the composers medium and so
the pay sucks compared to for sure but
the art is fantastic for sadist but it's
really I hate to say but I watch a movie
the music does make me cry it's
embarrassing that's what they are
[ __ ] any movie I've tried a lot of
times I think I don't do it anymore but
that was my job to make you cry yes but
a lot of times it really is the music
for that violin I did my first film
score and that's why I want an Oscar
thanks for that Adrian advice I'm
surprised you didn't bring it in Stuart
where do you keep your Oscar all my
Grammys are at my place just on the
mantel or you don't care no I don't have
I don't have a particular place I let it
roll you know right now it's probably in
my daughter's bedroom under the bed no
you don't have an hour place for it no I
have stuff I have stuff downstairs where
it's all kind of framed and hanging on
the wall and not a Grammy though you
know what the tradition of musicians
when you get your first gold disc the
place where it goes the powder room the
bathroom is that right and the reason
for that is very simple because you put
it on the wall in the living room and
people you know walk past that they see
it or they don't even notice it or
whatever but when it's in the bathroom
they have three minutes to contemplate
your greatness that's a great thing they
are alone they are alone undistracted
from your greatness I'm just getting a
telephone call now from Germany oh
you've won an Oscar
mr. hello sarih sorry you're sorry your
girlfriend or you know my wife is Fiona
Sarah is the record company in Hamburg
okay product manager yeah that's where
the Beatles cut their teeth that's right
that's right it's true that when you're
in the bathroom it gives you like every
word the inscription gets written and
read you know the appreciate have yeah
every every art yeah it's the way of
ramming it down their throat that's
right
what a great I guess see if it's more
than three minutes depending on what
you're serving for dinner you know for a
new band in England the thing used to be
that you know that you would have in
your bathroom you know long before you
got a Grammy or anything you would have
your holiday in towel in your bathroom
which is a very important message to any
visitor in your home which is I've been
to the States
I've I've toured America really so that
all-important holiday and the first
thing an English band does when they get
to America's I don't care where was -
gotta stay at a Holiday Inn and I got to
get that holiday inn towel but I can
hang in my bathroom back home it's a new
tradition with British bands I never
knew that
oh the Met being a number of times on my
heart was filled with with envy when I
went to somebody's house and they had a
holiday in town that's where I keep my
GED general equivalency diploma we get
when we drop out of high school I have
one and he has one yeah I was yeah I was
21 I got my GED I dropped that senior
year company here I dropped out you were
also you won the 10th best drummer of
all time in Rolling Stone does that mean
anything to you wants to be the other
words a DA was demoted years ago I was 5
and now I'm
in Italy I even in the top 100 could you
say 10 out of a thousand right yeah top
10 I think that's yeah 10th out of 10
just somehow doesn't have a ring to it
oh yeah top 10 yeah yeah you just made I
just squeaked in there who's right ahead
of you you know I don't know but I but
but the thing is that buddy rich isn't
even on that list so the whole thing is
kind of meaningless who's number one
who's considered is it Ginger Baker no
no no no no it's either these things go
around it's either Neil Peart who's a
good buddy of mine yeah although I've
been trying to chop him down for years
yeah but he's up the heat it's usually
Neil and/or Ringo or John Bonham Ringo
Neil Peart top 100 greatest drummers of
all time how is does it not Ginger Baker
though I mean even as crazy he doesn't
make it for some reason he was one of
mine I would have had him in the top ten
he's not on the list at all yeah he's
there somewhere I'll be he's on the top
the top Teddy I'm not in the top hunt
100 lists even of guitar players in
Rolling Stone
I've never made a list anywhere in my
life I think stone doesn't know I even
exist does it bother you never have does
it bother honestly I hate those [ __ ]
for you well you know they're pandering
they're kind of there I remember the
Playboy magazine used to have an annual
music you know the top guitarists hop
singer sure and the top sitar player one
year was George Harrison that gives you
an idea of the validity validity of
these lists but it does feel nice to be
mentioned like yeah it's funny like we
always say by critics I don't know what
they're talking about but nobody's ever
read a positive review and said critics
don't know what they're talking about
I'm guilty of a to know they do know
what they're talking about these are
guys you know musicians would hate to
own up to this and I've had arguments
with fellow musicians about this know
those guys do know what they're talking
about they have an opinion which might
not be the same as yours but they listen
to music every day much more closely
than you do you skinny musician yeah and
so I read all the views good bad and the
ugly and I've learned from bad reviews
I've learned from good reviews
yeah because as an artist you're
surrounded by people who tell you how
great you are yes people yeah
yes P in
a review whether it's hostile even if
the guy's a scumbag you'll learn
something that nobody around you would
have said what does hurt you in a review
has anything you read won't like only if
it's true yes it is have you read
something that was true that what made
you like oh god they saw that my first
orchestral piece which was a ballet for
the San Francisco Ballet
I learned the expression shoddy farrago
mm-hmm I had to look up jae-joon
noodling what's that mean I'll have to
look it up again that review was a
keeper and by the way it did suck it was
my first orchestral piece and it wasn't
great but there was four bars of it that
kicked ass
well kicked my ass okay and that was
what you know that was good that I got
to write more I gotta write more but
that review was such a scorched-earth
review that I that was a keeper that
when I've got that one framed nice you
guys right next to my Grammys you've all
seems pretty grounded though like again
again that's the the advantage of being
long-term musicians and you're working
together you both seem like you've seen
every aspect of the business you both
had tremendous successes you both won a
lot of [ __ ] so you're both kind of it's
it's like all right this stuff that
might throw a younger person or a newer
musician isn't gonna throw you off you
guys will probably work well together
does that make any sense
probably not well I still hate it when
reviewers try to try to convince people
that I'm losing my hair very much I've
worked on it for years it's an honor of
Frank Zappa by the way all I could think
of this whole interview is that you're
on that album it makes me crazy I love
that record so much it makes me sick how
much I love that right which record
shake your booty booty my favorite Zappa
was too into motels
I don't know I'm not a huge Zappa fan
I'm like that album is one of my
favorite games really is out of all his
55 or 60 records the number one seller
working Jewish princess dancing full
it's such an amazing great record well
I'm happy to meet you on their type the
word poop shoot even in that record you
have rabbits - that's a lovely term what
is the grape by the way rape was a
I was told this by I believe Patrick Oh
her and the bass player
it was a transvestite bar oh I thought
was a game okay yeah it's a reference in
one of the zapper songs yeah then I just
I great all I want to do is to hours and
talk about that song yeah okay well next
time you have me on the show yes we'll
talk about the great in Zappa okay